We are King Gnu. Thank you for having us.
Thank you.
Please introduce yourselves.
How did your band form?
What are the origins of your band name?
I'm bassist Kazuki Arai. Thanks for having me.
I'm Tsuneta.
I'm drummer Yu Seki.
I'm keyboardist Iguchi.
Originally it was a two-man group with Daiki.
Strictly speaking,
there was something before that,
but this four-man group started there,
and the two of us on the left joined later.
I joined through drummer Yu,
and Satoru is Daiki's childhood friend.
That's roughly how the band formed.
The band was originally called something else,
but we decided to change our name
when we debuted and became King Gnu.
There's an animal called the gnu.
Tsuneta came up with the idea.
The "gnu" symbolizes herd animals,
and "king" represents
the leader who guides them.
When the band formed,
you named a variety of
artists from Igor Stravinsky
to Jimi Hendrix as your influences.
Have you been influenced by
more artists since then?
Yes, on a regular basis.
It changes all the time.
Whoever's hot at the time.
Yeah, whoever's hot or big at the time.
Right.
Each of us has our own little influences.
Yeah.
Yu likes that drummer
with the persistent sound.
Yeah.
Yu likes that drummer
with the persistent sound.
Chad.
Right, Chad.
I feel like your sound
shifted at some point, too.
Do you have any, Satoru?
What?
Lately I've been listening to R&B.
Really?
Yeah.
What have you been listening to recently?
Daniel Caesar.
Daniel Caesar? Really?
Yes, really.
You do?
Yeah, I make sure to.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Recently post-Jpop has been
a hidden theme in my sound.
Really?
Recently post-Jpop has been
a hidden theme in my sound.
Really?
Much more than before.
In terms of our music, when did you
start thinking about a post-Jpop sound?
Since Ceremony, I think.
So starting with the songs
for our recent album.
It really started this year.
So starting with the songs
for our recent album.
It really started this year.
Now that you mention it, you're right.
I know what you mean.
You're right. You can hear it
in our recent recordings.
Your music is sometimes
described as Tokyo mixture rock.
How is King Gnu's music evolving over time?
I'm not sure.
But I do sense our sound evolved in this album.
Yeah.
I can't express exactly what that is
since the album just came out recently,
but I definitely feel it. You can sense it.
Next question.
"SPECIALZ" is the perfect opening theme for
the JUJUTSU KAISEN Shibuya Incident arc.
Were you fans of the JUJUTSU KAISEN anime
or manga before writing the song?
I actually like the
Shibuya Incident arc quite a bit.
Yeah.
I actually like the
Shibuya Incident arc quite a bit.
I'm glad we got to write a song for that.
Yeah.
The content is complex, you know?
Like all the...
Both the setting and techniques.
Like the setting?
I actually reread the story from the
beginning since it was being animated.
It's a lot of fun.
Yeah.
I want to know what happens next.
Right? Don't you guys?
Yeah, I'm pretty curious
to know what will happen.
Right? Don't you guys?
I'm very curious.
Yeah, I'm pretty curious
to know what will happen.
I'm very curious.
Right? Isn't your interest piqued?
My interest is piqued right now.
Right? Isn't it?
Okay.
Tsuneta and Iguchi's vocals produce a beautiful
call and response melody in "SPECIALZ".
This sequence in the music video seems to
depict a hero versus villain dynamic.
Was this inspired by JUJUTSU KAISEN?
Well, the whole thing is.
Right. You're right. The whole thing is.
But it's not really hero versus villain.
Yeah.
Maybe they're both villains.
Both of you?
I guess so.
But... it's true though, in all things.
There isn't always a right side.
It depends on your perspective.
You're right. That's sort of true
of the Shibuya Incident arc.
Did you go too deep?
Yeah.
That was too much.
He jumped in to save you.
Now we can drown together.
You've written songs for other anime including
Ranking of Kings, JUJUTSU KAISEN 0,
and Banana Fish.
How does writing songs for anime
differ from writing songs for albums?
The style of my music is more suited
to anime than the real world,
so it's easier for me to write for anime.
Really?
There's a lot of freedom.
I guess it's true that anime is
often a better match for us.
Probably because the scale is so large.
Writing for melodramatic Japanese
TV shows is pretty difficult.
Yeah.
The music video for Teenager Forever
gives us a look at the members
and their personal lives.
No way. Really?
Were there any special moments
that didn't make it into the final cut?
Satoru, you visited a bunch of places.
You mean the Philippines?
What did you do there?
What?
It was a lot of fun.
What did you do there?
What?
Does that mean
it's pretty much all in the video?
There's really not that much.
I guess the music video
features the softest parts.
That was all we could show.
There were things that were
too beautiful to include,
like walks on the beach and holding hands.
Holding hands, huh?
We couldn't include that.
I see.
Your music video for Hakujitsu won
video of the year at MTV VMAJ 2019.
Compared to other King Gnu music videos,
the art direction in this
video seems different.
Why do you think this video won?
Yeah. It was a deliberate choice
to make it like that.
Yeah.
It's in the style of a public
recording or performance.
Yeah.
We brought in a pianist.
Including a story felt cheap, so we
wanted to do something different.
I think it turned out well since we didn't
add any weird additional meaning.
What are your current career goals?
As a band, we'd like to have
a success dome tour.
Yeah.
We're pouring all our effort
into that right now.
Yeah, a dome tour.
We're pouring all our effort
into that right now.
There's not much else.
Congratulations on releasing
your first album in four years.
You decided on the title
THE GREATEST UNKNOWN four years ago.
Could you tell us the meaning behind it?
After finishing Ceremony, I wanted to
preserve our offstage perspective.
It's the reason I write music,
so I wanted to return to that perspective.
I really value being outside of the spotlight.
Now for the rapid-fire questions.
What's your favorite anime?
Anime?
Anime.
One answer each. Go ahead.
Ghost in the Shell.
Ghost in the Shell?
Okay. Yu?
Yellow Submarine.
That brings back memories.
Studio Ghibli. Isao Takahata's works.
I recently watched and enjoyed Hell's Paradise.
Oh, yeah? It was good?
It was really interesting.
What kind of anime did you watch as a child?
Go ahead.
Mobile Suit Gundam.
Really? SEED?
No, First.
First?
Pokémon, probably.
Pokémon and Ghibli.
Probably Conan.
Conan, huh?
Inuyasha.
Oh, that brings back memories.
It was in that time slot.
Yeah, it was always anime.
Right, it was Inuyasha and Conan.
That brings back memories.
Inuyasha is my answer.
Are there any artists or bands
you'd like to collaborate with?
I'd like to be drawn by Inoue-sensei from
Slam Dunk and Oda-sensei from One Piece.
So you're looking at artists broadly speaking.
I'd like to be drawn by Inoue-sensei from
Slam Dunk and Oda-sensei from One Piece.
So you're looking at artists broadly speaking.
I'd like to be drawn as a character
in Eiichiro Oda's style.
What are three songs you've
been listening to recently?
The other day Daiki told me about Ralphie...
Ralphie Choo.
Ralphie Choo is sick.
He's sick.
Simon Barker, Scott Tinkler, and Bae il Dong.
They're an Australian jazz trio.
Oh, those are their names.
Yeah. I've been listening
to that Australian jazz trio.
Huh.
What about you, Satoru?
I've been listening to Sufjan Stevens recently.
The folk artist?
Yeah.
Kazuki, have you been listening
to Bon Iver recently?
Not recently.
The new Sampha album, NewJeans, and the Marías.
That's what I've been listening to recently.
It's hard to narrow it down to three
since I listen to entire albums.
What did you want to be when you grew up?
What was your childhood dream?
In kindergarten I wanted to be a cameraman.
A cameraman?
Classy.
That's cool. That's so cool.
Is it?
Is being a cameraman really that cool?
I guess.
Thomas, I think.
Thomas?
I liked Thomas.
I wanted to be Thomas.
Is that why you chose that look for SPECIALZ?
Was there anything Thomas-like about that?
Your face on the rocket.
Oh, you mean the rocket?
You could collab with Thomas.
You're right.
Then your dream came true.
I guess so.
I think I wanted to be a hero.
Like a Sentai hero?
I wanted to be a basketball player.
Really?
Yeah. I wrote about it in an essay.
I looked up to Yuta Tabuse.
I gave up after about seven months.
Do you prefer action or romance?
We'll start with Saku. Action or romance?
Action or romance? What does that mean?
Like what do you prefer?
Yeah.
That's a weird question.
They're both good.
You're right.
Okay.
Next question.
Any other instruments you'd like to learn?
Instruments we'd like to learn?
Instruments we'd like to learn, huh?
I kind of think the oboe is cool.
You seem like an oboist.
I'd like to.
I really like it.
It's great. I like the sound.
It's good.
Oboe, then?
All of us?
Everyone?
So we're all choosing oboe?
We're all choosing oboe.
It's time for the Most Likely To Game.
Who's most likely to win an Oscar?
Ready, and...
It's split two-two.
It's two-two.
I think it's me.
Yu, then.
I'd like to see him in a weird role.
Like Gollum.
That's a supporting role.
And not a leading role?
But he has such strong presence.
So you weren't imagining him in a leading role.
He's vital to the movie.
So I'd win Best Supporting Actor.
Yeah.
Who seems most likely to eat
one of Sukuna's fingers?
What is this? What kind of question
is this? Who wrote this?
Let's try it. Who's most likely to eat one?
Ready, and...
What?
It's Yu.
No way.
There's something going on here.
I chose Satoru.
You only picked me because I like to eat.
You think I'll eat anything.
He'd probably eat it if you passed it to him.
Like along with some food.
Who's funniest or most interesting?
Suddenly a deep question.
What makes a person interesting?
We're all interesting in our own ways.
Ready, and—
Wait. I haven't chosen yet.
I don't think I can choose.
I can't choose.
I can't answer this one. I can't choose.
I thought it might be Satoru, but...
The obvious answer is Satoru.
Publicly, yeah.
Publicly?
But he's not nearly as interesting at home.
I'm really boring. For real.
He's really boring at home.
All I do is talk to my cat.
Like, "What is it, kitty?"
Who would be first to die in a horror movie?
If the four of us were in a horror movie.
In other words, who seems
most like a minor character.
It's probably me.
Really?
I don't really think so.
You seem like you'd be one of the final three.
It's always someone interesting.
Suppose there're three people left,
and someone has to die
for the group to progress.
Right, that trope.
Who would die then?
Ugh, that's the worst.
I'll do it.
Man, that's not fair.
Don't volunteer. That's not fair.
You're volunteering?
Who's the best dancer?
Could you dance for us a little?
Well, this one is easy.
Ready, and...
That was quick.
Okay. That's all for now.
There were a lot of unusual questions,
but we hope you learned something about us.
We were King Gnu.